all right joining me now is Governor Ron
DeSantis 2024 GOP Presidential candidate
Governor I found what happened this
weekend in Vietnam no longer to be funny
I found it to be extremely disturbing
and the Press making any effort to cover
for this at this point is even more
pathetic if that's possible
well look I mean this is a guy that
that's stumbling around the world stage
he's projecting weakness I think our
enemies have already taken advantage of
that they're like it's likely to invite
even more problems around the world and
so you know it's sad but I think it's
obvious that that he's been struggling
for quite some time and you're right the
corporate press is going to do whatever
they can to run interference for him and
I also look and think about who's
waiting in the wings with Kamala and I
think you're right in terms of the
aptitude uh even though she's a lot
younger I think she's basically been his
impeachment Insurance because people
know no matter how bad Biden is nobody
wants Harris and that's just the reality
and that's a sad situation America finds
ourselves in meanwhile our country is in
a state of decline I mean we see it
across the board in terms of our
strength abroad our economy here at home
our culture our education system and
Biden's really been the custodian of
that decline
well Governor I think what what
Americans are really really worried
about is that we don't know who's in
charge who's making these decisions do
you have a theory about that obviously
if if you're the nominee and you win I
I've known you for a long time you're
going to make decisions you always make
the decisions I don't think anyone ever
has a doubt about you but in this White
House do you have a theory who's
deciding the big issues I think you have
a lot of very left-wing aides and
staffers in the white house and I think
you have a line to to people like
Valerie Jarrett Obama I think they're
all involved behind the scenes pushing
him in a very left-wing Direction I mean
his presidency he's been more left-wing
than Obama's was even uh and he
presented himself as being a more
moderate candidate when he ran in 2020
and I think that's a result of these
folks really pushing the envelope I mean
they just opened a civil rights
investigation against the State of
Florida one of our College's new College
of Sarasota I appointed conservative
trustees they reoriented the University
from being left of the left to being
classical education like Hillsdale and
they did things like abolish the gender
studies department and they're now
opening up a civil rights investigation
against one of our trustees Chris Ruffo
because he misgendered one of the fired
employees or fired professors you've got
to be kidding me they're basically
saying that there's a civil right to
have things like gender studies and
pronouns in our colleges and
universities no one would have thought
that was possible even five years ago
Governor can we expect you to actually
go into urban areas that are
predominantly Democrat
with a lot of minority voters who've
been skeptical and they would say for
good reason of the Republicans and their
intentions
will you have or do you have plans to
work to try to gain support among
minority and urban voters where
Republicans have not done as well as
they should have done given the record
of the Democrats of course that's what
we did in Florida Laura I won Miami-Dade
County which is our most Urban County
2.8 million people that's more than some
states have in population 70 percent
Latino also strong African-American we
want it by double digits a republican
hadn't won it in many many years we also
won counties like Palm Beach which are
Republican had won in 40 years and so
some of the most heavily Urban counties
we were winning in Florida and so I
think the formula is one don't Pander to
people and try to divide them on
ethnicity treat them and us As Americans
we're all we all want the same things
low crime we will crack down on crime
nationally with these Soros backed
prosecutors I did it in Florida I'll do
it nationally the border and immigration
illegal in immigration is having a
devastating effect on a lot of these
urban areas people are flooding their
school systems and hospitals I'm going
to shut the border down we'll build the
wall and we're going to use lethal Force
against the Mexican drug cartels leaving
them stone cold dead at the border if
they're trying to bring fentanyl in and
then education Laura we're doing school
choice in every inner city in this
country we did it in Florida our results
have skyrocketed over the last decade as
a result of that it works and these kids
deserve a chance well can just yes or no
will we expect campaign appearances in
Chicago you know South Side L.A Boston
Hartford I mean that's we're going to
see those appearances yes and I think we
have no choice as Republicans Laura if
every urban area goes 90-10 Democrat
then we have this high wire act to try
to squeeze out enough voters you're not
going to win these urban areas but if
you just improve that is a huge huge
possibility by
final question Biden spoke in Alaska on
his way back from um from the the G20
Summit a 911 today you're in New York
City
um he says he was there and it was okay
because after Pearl Harbor people didn't
go to Pearl Harbor you know every
December 7th so tell us about your trip
to New York my wife and I got invited by
some of the 911 families who we've
gotten to know and so we went I wasn't
in like the VIP section with these
politicians I was walking around the
site with the families we would go to
where their family members names were
and it was really emotional because
they're telling stories and the way
they've done it is someone that passed
away the names of people that knew each
other close by so they're telling
stories about maybe their father's
friends or husband's friends and so my
wife and I were really touched by it and
we are committed uh and and I also think
back to 911 that that inspired me to
join the military I mean my whole life
change as a result of that serving in
Iraq serving in the Navy and ending up
getting involved in public service and
so my wife and I were really touched by
it and I've said as president you know
they've been promised the documents on
the Saudi involvement they've been
promised a lot of things over the year
we got to deliver for these 911 families
and I will do that hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else